would you rather spend the rest of your  life blind or inside an olive garden  um whoa that's a good one  the rest of your life is in the olive  garden yeah  i've never been in an olive garden i  don't think i have either  but i could i mean so like it's just  that'd be a great tv there  so you like watch tv of course yeah yeah  yeah salad  i can have show everything can come to  me it's like being like  like when you're like a cartel boss in  jail yeah this is like cartel boss in  jail all the food that you want  inside the olive garden hands down are  you kidding me be blind  why would you want to be blind because  you can't see anything anyway you're  basically in the olive garden  but then you get to see everything